hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast I have the distinct honor of
sitting this morning with Dr Asim
malhorta who is a Consulting
cardiologist president of the scientific
advisory committee of the public health
collaboration a best-selling author
among many other distinctions Dr
malharta Welcome To Dark Horse
thank you Brett lovely to be here
so
many in my audience will be familiar
with your story but some will not I know
you as someone who has been a very
forceful voice in the covet dissident
Community but a late emerging one
do you want to explain how you ended up
as a coveted dissident before we get
into the questions that are raised by it
sure
um it's a great question Brett so
I think for me uh more recently this
label of being a cover dissident has
come from my U-turn if you like or I
would more likely want to describe it as
evolution in my understanding of the
benefits and harms of the covid-19
vaccine specifically the MRNA vaccine to
the Pfizer moderna vaccines
and I was actually one of the public
advocates
very early on in the pandemic
um when the vaccine rollout started in
in December of 2020 January 2021
I was one of the first to take two doses
of the fisa vaccine
and a month later I was actually on Good
Morning Britain
trying to help tackle uh in a
compassionate way vaccine hesitancy
which was particularly prevalent amongst
the ethnic minority communities in the
UK and I know that's similar in the US
because I convinced a friend of mine
who's a well-known film director called
grinder cheddar well known for movies
like Bend It Like Beckham Blinded By the
Light which is on Bruce Springsteen
um she was receiving a lot of what at
the time I felt was in quotes
um anti-vaxx misinformation through
blogs and asked me around
um whether or not she should take the
vaccine and I I said to her listen
vaccines and I still believe this to be
the case in traditional vaccines
certainly uh one of the most safest
pharmacological interventions in the
history of medicine so I didn't in any
way shape or form even conceive of the
possibility
of any vaccine causing significant harm
let alone the covered vaccines
but over a period of around a year Brett
um
my
um opinion changed quite significantly
because of a number of different events
um probably the first that made me think
about it was my father who was a retired
doctor
um the honorary vice president of the
British Medical Association very
well-known doctor he suffered
um a unexplained and unexpected sudden
cardiac death in July of 2021.
um I was actually involved in the whole
uh in the events leading up to his death
because he'd called me
um he was suffering from chest pain
which sounded cardiac I was in London he
was in Manchester so a couple hundred
miles away
and we were on the phone and in between
our phone calls he suffered a cardiac
arrest which was witnessed by
two of his neighbors who were doctors
and despite the fact that they uh
carried out CPR immediately and
ambulances called there was a delay in
the ambulance Etc and I was down the
line so it was quite a harrowing
experience for me but
um and of course he was also on a
personal level I was very very close to
him he was my best friend I knew his
lifestyle habits inside out he was the
last surviving member of my immediate
family so I had a quite a profound
effect on me but
um because of the fact that he was
otherwise well and I knew his cardiac
history which was non-significant
um I I asked for a post-mortem to be
carried out
and it's post-mortem findings were quite
shocking he had two critical or severe
stenosis or narrowings in three out of
three of the major arteries two of them
were severely narrowed and um that would
suggest certainly compared to scans I'd
organized a few years earlier just
routine stuff they had a rapid
acceleration of of his blockages so you
know my area of interest and research a
lot of my advocacy over the years Brett
has been on changing the understanding
of our heart disease develops but also
what can be done to even potentially
Halt and even reverse heart disease
that's you know I've published on this
stuff extensively you may be aware of
that work so if anybody had has
expertise in understanding this it's me
and it didn't make sense and the only
thing I could attribute it at the time
my only explanation which again didn't
fully fit but I thought well you know
you have to think about all the
possibilities was my father under very
profound severe psychological stress
that caused an acceleration of his
cardiotic disease
um and then a few months later
a number of different bits of data
emerged
um which for me started to put a picture
together to suggest that the MRNA
vaccines could be
um that a major cause behind my dad's
death and of course many other uh
unexpected cardiac arrests and heart
attacks and that was first and foremost
there was an abstract published in
circulation by Stephen gundry which
suggested that the MRNA vaccines were
causing huge coronary inflammation
through inflammatory markers that would
increase cardiovascular risk very
rapidly
um at the same time a colleague
from a very prestigious British
institution I won't name name that
institution
um to protect his uh identity but he
basically said that um researchers at
his institution had accidentally found
by use of coronary Imaging that the
vaccinated versus unvaccinated were
having huge
um increases in uh coronary inflammation
as well
having found this they decided they had
a closed meeting that they were not
going to publish these findings because
they were worried about
the fact that they may lose funding from
the pharmaceutical industry and then
only a few weeks earlier I had been
contacted by a journalist for the Times
newspaper and actually given an
interview
um where she said that there was reports
from hospitals in Scotland of a uh
unexplained rise in heart attacks about
25 increased risk and heart attacks
which were not associated with covid and
asked me what was the cause of that now
before I'd become familiar with these
potential harms from the vaccine I had
again attributed it to
maybe the knock-on effect of lockdowns
poor diet and stress because actually
the major factors normally in the
development of heart disease 80 of heart
diseases is lifestyle related are issues
such as poor diet sanitary lifestyle
poor sleep and and chronic psychological
stress so I had predicted there probably
would be a signal anyway coming in the
next few years even when the pandemic
started from those factors and I still
think they probably play a role
um but then I decided Brett after all of
this to
um first and foremost as a my duty as a
doctor and because I have a public
profile I went on GB news which is a
news channel over here and I said that
you know I'm concerned there may be a
significant link here between the MRNA
vaccines and heart heart attacks and it
needs investigating
um that video went viral
um I had to put up behind the scenes
many people don't know this but after
that um I had a couple of very uh um
let's put it this way a medical
organizations linked to my medical
license and my affiliation my
postgraduate um credentials essentially
contact me because of complaints that
were made by Anonymous doctors I was
promoting you know anti-vaxx information
Etc so I had to deal with that in the
meantime over a few weeks and that
luckily didn't end in any specific
censorship
um but I then decided what I needed to
do really to open this up is to spend my
time
critically appraising the data
thoroughly and then publishing it in a
medical journal and I did this over a
period of nine months and as you
probably know
um a few weeks ago I published these two
papers in the Journal of incident
resistance where I had concluded
um unequivocally based upon the evidence
that the um the MRNA vaccines need to be
suspended uh pending an inquiry because
the signal of harm is significant and
it's based upon very high quality
evidence now
it is a long answer and there are quite
a number of things I want to return to
in there but I think first and foremost
let me just say
um that's a terrible story about your
father and uh I'm you have my
condolences and I'm sure my audience is
properly shocked by
um what must have been uh
uh at a terrible
realization not only of
his passing but of the possibility that
um your profession had been involved in
some way in advancing a therapy that had
this terrible terrible consequence so
anyway thank you Brad and then on that
note the irony of this is my father
obviously it had two doses of vaccine
early on he had actually convinced me
because I realized I knew I was low risk
from covert and I'm sure we can talk
about that a bit later but
um he had really convinced me
emotionally because you know he had lost
his wife my mother a few years ago just
to get into the human side of it and I
think that he like many people who are
older had a a very I would say
exaggerated fear of covid
and for him obviously I'm his you know
only surviving son
um and uh he you know he was worried
about me and he said listen please you
know and actually one of the main
reasons I had it was because I didn't I
didn't necessarily need to have it so
quickly I could have waited it's because
of him uh and also as somebody that was
the honorary vice president of BMA and
he also was a prolific writer he did a
lot of media work he was a very strong
Advocate again for the vaccine as well
so that's also you know they're they're
thrown into the picture which
complicates the situation
yeah it sure does I I will say
um I also received pressure from people
who loved me and wanted me to get
vaccinated
um and in in fact at the beginning of
the vaccination campaign I thought I
would I was pretty excited about the
vaccines in our book Heather and I
discussed the danger of hyper novelty
which is making modern people sick both
physically and psychologically
two of the most common disorders are
anxiety and depression our first sponsor
mind Bloom is a leader in the treatment
of anxiety and depression using at home
ketamine therapy it is a combination of
science-backed Medicine with clinician
guidance and support for people looking
to improve mental health and increase
their sense of well-being
mind Bloom connects patients to licensed
psychiatric professionals to help them
achieve better outcomes with lower costs
greater convenience and an artfully
crafted experience
to begin take mind Bloom's online
assessment and schedule a video consult
with a licensed clinician to determine
if mind Bloom is right for you
if approved you'll discuss your health
history and goals for mental health
treatment with your clinician to tailor
your mind Bloom regimen
mindbloom will send you a kit in the
mail complete with medicine treatment
materials and tips for getting the most
out of your experience
after only two sessions 87 percent of
Mind Bloom clients reported improvements
in depression and 85 percent reported
improvements in anxiety
it's time to enter the next chapter in
mental health and well-being let mind
Bloom guide you
right now mind Bloom is offering our
listeners a hundred dollars off your
first six session program when you sign
up at mindbloom.com
Darkhorse and use the promo code
Darkhorse at checkout
go to mindbloom.com Darkhorse promo code
Darkhorse for a hundred dollars off your
first six session program today that's
mindbloom.com
Darkhorse promo code Darkhorse our
second sponsor is American Hartford gold
inflation is at its highest level in 40
years we all feel it at the grocery
store and the fuel pump interest rates
are soaring retirement accounts are in
danger
if you want to protect your family's
financial future you should consider
that people have been putting wealth
into precious metals for thousands of
years
the more uncertain access to other
stores of value gets the more precious
precious metals are likely to become
call American Hartford gold to see how
easy it is to get started they can show
you how to protect your savings and
retirement accounts by diversifying your
portfolio with physical gold and silver
you can hold in your hand
all it takes to get started is a short
phone call and they'll have gold and
silver delivered right to your door or
inside your IRA or 401k
they are the highest rated firm in the
country with an A plus rating from the
Better Business Bureau and thousands of
satisfied clients
call them now and they will give you a
percentage of your first qualifying
order back in free silver
call American Hartford gold at
866-828-1117 that's
866-828-1117 or text Darkhorse to
998899 again that's
866-828-1117 or text Darkhorse to 998899
do you know what a laundry suit is
it's that clothing you wear when you are
finally forced to do your laundry
do you know what the opposite of a
laundry suit is
the stuff you read for first when your
clothes come out of the dryer it's your
favorite shirt for example
when mizen and Main contacted us about
sponsoring the show I had never heard of
them it turns out they specialize in the
design and manufacture of favorite
shirts
when I got my first package from mizen
in Maine it was instant love the quality
is obvious at first touch
Maine are the inventors of the
performance fabric dress shirt they make
really comfortable clothes
these shirts combine the comfort and
flexibility of your favorite athletic
wear with the fit and style of a custom
dress shirt it's lightweight breathable
and moisture wicking they are actually
the best shirts I've worn
they are machine washable and that means
no more expensive trips to the dry
cleaner Plus for cold weather they've
got amazing flannels pants sweaters and
jackets made from the same Mison and
Main material they've become famous for
they've got over thirty thousand five
star reviews so you know their stuff is
high quality
if you wear dress shirts and haven't
tried missing in Maine you're missing
out it really has become my favorite
shirt
so if you want the best cold weather
clothing find your next favorite shirt
at mizzen in Maine right now if you go
to Mission and Main and use the promo
code Darkhorse you'll receive 25 off any
regular price order of 130 or more
that's 25 off when you go to
m-i-z-z-e-n-a-n-d m a i n.com and use
our promo code Darkhorse
our final sponsor for this episode is
Vivo barefoot shoes made for feet
most shoes are made for someone's idea
of feet not vivos vivos are feet first
foot forward shoes that will change your
approach to walking
vivos are made by people people with
feet who know how to use them here at
Darkhorse we love these shoes they are
Beyond comfortable the tactile feedback
from the surfaces you're walking on is
amazing and they cause no pain at all
because there are no pressure points
forcing your feet into odd positions
they're simply fantastic
our feet are the product of millions of
years of evolution humans evolve to walk
move and run Barefoot but modern shoes
that are overly cushioned and strangely
shaped have negatively impacted foot
function and are contributing to a
Health crisis one in which people move
less than they might in part because
their shoes make their feet hurt
Vivo barefoot shoes are designed wide to
provide natural stability thin to enable
you to feel more and flexible to help
you build your natural foot strength
from the ground up foot strength
increases by 60 in a matter of months
just by walking around in them
the number of people wearing Vivo
barefoots is growing once people start
wearing these shoes they don't seem to
stop
Evo Barefoot has a great range of
Footwear for kids and adults for every
activity from hiking to training as well
as everyday wear they're a certified B
Corp pioneering regenerative business
principles and their Footwear is
produced using sustainably sourced
natural and recycled materials with the
aim to protect the natural world so you
can run wild on it
go to Vivo barefoot.com
Darkhorse to get an exclusive 20 off
additionally all new customers get a
100-day free trial so you can see if you
love them as much as we do that's Vivo
v-a-r-e-f-o-o-t.com slash Darkhorse I'll
give a little history here Heather and I
were finishing the first draft of our
book deep in the Amazon
um in late 2019 early 2020
as we emerged from our isolation from
contact with the Civilized world
the first hints of Novel coronavirus
circulating reached our phones as they
came awake and in the book that we had
just completed the first draft of we
said that vaccines are one of the three
greatest triumphs of medicine the other
two being antibiotics and surgery so I
do consider myself
uh very nearly a vaccine enthusiast
um and that was my
um my bent at the point that these
vaccines were or so-called vaccines I
would now say were announced
now the all that has transpired since
these uh inoculations have emerged has
caused me to rethink my position
a bit I now am
still very enthusiastic about the
fundamental underlying uh intervention
that a proper vaccine delivers it's a
lot of bang for the buck and the amount
of good that can be done with these
things is tremendous but I do think
um that there are various Technologies
involved with making vaccines and some
of them are now suspect may be
destructive in other words I think I did
not give enough Credence to the vaccine
hesitancy that predated covid and I know
I heard a recent conversation you had
with Bobby Kennedy Jr and I think he
raised the same point about adjuvants
and possible allergies to food and other
things that may be triggered by them
which is a position I share with him
but in any case let's say you and I both
start out from a position of feeling
that vaccines are a a marvelous
Discovery and potentially critically
important in protecting human health but
that something has gone awry at the very
least in the context of covid
um I know that my awareness you know I
had the initial uh sense of relief upon
hearing that we had vaccines that were
uh being readied for delivery and then
as a biologist and somebody with a
little bit of training in immunobiology
I started to hear just how novel these
particular inoculants were
and hearing how novel they were coupled
with the claim that they were
exceedingly safe raised alarm bells for
me because I knew that a vaccine that
was truly functioning by a novel
mechanism
that had only been around for a a short
number of months could not possibly be
known to be safe even if it would
ultimately be proved harmless there's no
way anybody could tell you that it was
ultimately going to be harmless and so
that alarm caused Heather and me to
decide to delay although we thought we
would be vaccinated we decided let's
wait we were not initially eligible and
we said actually we're in no rush let's
wait let's give it you know a couple
months to see if an adverse event signal
shows up that tells us anything that we
would want to know before making that
decision and of course the longer we
waited the stranger the story became yes
the adverse event signal did begin to
show up and no nobody seemed to be
paying attention to it they seem to be
deliberately avoiding the information
and so I think
I would be remiss if I did not point out
that one of the strangest features of
the story that you have just told is
your reaction which is highly unusual
amongst doctors I don't think it should
be but I have now watched doctor after
doctor fail to make eye contact with
this pattern and it does raise a
question that I have been very eager to
pose to you which is
at this point we have a an absolutely
alarming and unprecedented signal not
only in the vares system here in the U.S
but in the yellow card system in Europe
and in the American Military system
which is completely isolated from any of
the the things that people accuse of air
system of
the pattern is clear
how is it possible
that doctors are not rising up on mass
and telling us wait a minute something
has emerged in the context of these
vaccines that ought to have us at the
very least going exceedingly slow if not
as you propose simply ending the program
until we know what's taking place yeah
it's a great question Brad I think just
to add in you're absolutely right we've
got this pharmacovigilance data in the
US UK unprecedented unprecedented
reports of Harms
um for example in the UK um for the
Pfizer vaccine there were 500 000 half a
million
um Adverse Events reported on the yellow
card scheme
um which uh is is unheard of and uh that
you know people don't fill in these
these yellow cards or the vars unless
there's something significant it isn't
usually even people have a sore arm or a
fever they don't report on these on
these so there's clearly something there
but what I would say before answering
your question directly
for me the icing on the cake if you like
or The Smoking Gun is the uh re-analysis
of Pfizer moderna's original randomized
control trials by
um you know very eminent scientist
Joseph Freeman who I've spoken to lead
Author Peter Doshi from University of
Maryland associated with the bmj Robert
Kaplan from Stanford is a published in
vaccine peer review journal is they were
found in the original trials the this
the rate of serious Adverse Events was
about one in 800 for every 800 people
vaccinated in the trial there was one
serious adverse event and and what's
most extraordinary rare is they were you
were more likely to suffer a serious
adverse event in the original RCT
then one was to suffer um
hospitalization from covid so what that
tells so we've actually got the highest
possible quality level of data there's
you know there's not even observational
this is randomized controlled trial
evidence for me that which should be
more than enough
um to suspend the vaccine because that
is a very you know very significant and
very strong quality data so the question
is why is there this turning a blind eye
so I think the best way to describe it
um is willful blindness
so this is a a condition something that
happens in with human beings it can
happen in um in individual relationships
we're all capable of it it can be you
know in in a way that people maybe turn
a blind eye or to the fact that their
spouse may be cheating on them it can
happen in institutions we see what
happened with for example in Hollywood
and Harvey Weinstein
um it can happen in populations and
countries you know what happened in Nazi
Germany for example how did the German
population not know for so long that
Jewish people were being massacred in
concentration camps or maybe they didn't
know but they turned a blind eye so we
call this war for blindness and to
Define it more specifically it's when
humans turn the Blind Eye to the truth
in order to feel safe
to avoid conflict
um to reduce anxiety and to protect
Prestige and I think that's what we are
seeing now in relation to many people's
reaction to this issue about covered
vaccine harms I think one other thing to
throw into the equation as well which I
was thinking about recently
um Brett is that
um fear
is inversely correlated with people's
ability to engage in critical thinking
and many of the people I think certainly
if you look at the reaction certainly
anecdotally and there's definitely been
there was a greater fear and
understandably so amongst older
populations around covid and I think
those people are also the same people
who are probably more likely to be
really adherent to masking
Etc and I think that that is still
playing a role because many people still
have this very grossly exaggerated fear
of covet and therefore in order to feel
safe when they were offered and said
listen we've got this solution it's
going to end the pandemic here's the
vaccine they embraced it wholeheartedly
and I still and I think it's very
difficult for them to suddenly it's not
easy for those people to suddenly change
their minds and of course you know
um Jordan Peterson talks about this so
changing one's mind is one of the most
terrifying experiences a human being can
face uh in Academia we know that you
know there's a there's a great quote
from John Kenneth Galbraith the Canadian
American Economist who said you know
faced with a choice between changing
one's mind and proving there's no reason
to do so
almost everybody gets busy on the proof
so I think we have to try and understand
that The Human Condition to explain some
of this Behavior but
um the way to tackle it is actually just
by by addressing those issues or those
um uh those um that denialism with cold
hard facts but to doing a compassionate
way so I think when people understand
that we're all capable for blame as I
could say to some degree I will I was
willfully blind when I was being told
that the vaccine could be causing
problems certainly for a while
then I think that's a way to approach
trying to get more and more people on
board
well I I hear what you're saying and I'm
all for approaching this compassionately
to a point but nonetheless you are
describing a failure that words seen in
the general public okay but we're
talking about doctors and what I have
witnessed is
doctors who are in no way Fringe highly
decorated fully qualified doctors in the
exact area you would hope they would be
in order to make such a pronouncement
attempting to raise the alarm of their
colleagues and being
demonized and stigmatized and
marginalized in many cases
systematically
now
I guess I think one cannot have it both
ways
that happens it has caused doctors to
recoil in fear to make themselves and I
100 agree with your diagnosis it is a
blindness that is on uh the user's side
they are willfully blinding themselves
to a pattern that you couldn't miss if
you were just simply uh committed to an
objective analysis
but for doctors to be vulnerable to that
within their own areas of specialty in
many cases says something about
the state of medical education it says
something about the incentives that
surround doctoring
and
uh I know that it has left me in a
predicament where
I'm literally afraid to go to the doctor
even if I was if I broke my leg
um I know what conversation I'm going to
have when I arrive at the ER and the
conversation is going to involve my
vaccination status and at the point that
I say I am not vaccinated for covid
um most doctors will look at me as if I
have just confessed to an
anti-scientific highly political bent
when all I've really done is just simply
looked at my own health looked at the
actual evidence of utility of the
vaccines looked at the evidence of the
potential harms and decided that no cost
benefit analysis could possibly justify
my accepting these things
so uh I guess
you know you're obviously a very
uh decent person and I hear I hear you
looking out for you know the
vulnerabilities the psychological
vulnerabilities that make this happen to
people and uh trying to be careful about
how we approach it but haven't you just
um
if we look at your your argument from
the other side haven't we just
effectively indicted your profession
yeah right we have
um and I you know I have uh I
communicate in different ways and I'm
considered quite forthright and a bit of
a Maverick and uh and very assertive in
My Views throughout my career whether
it's around cholesterol or sugar or
statins or corruption in the drug
industry
um
I'm with you completely and I think it's
it's very this is we're not just
fighting for
transparency of data in relation to the
vaccine and
fighting for
um those people who've been vaccine
injured
uh and fighting for what I would say is
really a pause in the vaccine and
investigation we're also fighting for
really um the medical profession now and
in terms of restoring trust because the
trust is clearly gone to a significant
degree we know that the certainly in the
UK we are seeing the fact that even for
the traditional vaccines we've talked
about which you know in comparison to
most of the drugs are extremely safe and
have proven very effective that there's
been a um a reduction in people
attending or having uptake for things
like MMR measle mops and rubella
vaccines and that is a uh is symptomatic
of the fact that there is clearly a
reduction in trust and that reduction in
trust has happened because of these
coercive policies that have been pushed
by many of establishment doctors
and I think that that is
um something that will take a long time
um to to restore that trust but we have
to do what we can as a best and to the
best of our ability
right now to make sure that that
shift and that acknowledgment happened
sooner rather than later but
um I'm completely with you I I get it
and I think that some of it also
unfortunately Brett is based upon the
fact that he's you know you've hinted at
these structural drivers these perverse
incentives in the Healthcare System
anyway
um we know for example we've been
pre-covered it's something I talk about
as a very you know vocal Advocate and
campaigner for a sustainable National
Health Service
um which you know was founded on the
principles of giving
um Everybody the best care uh free at
the point of views is that the American
Healthcare System in an example where
you have some of the highest expenditure
on Healthcare in the world and certainly
within the developed countries some of
the worst Health outcomes and that's
pre-covered and one of the reasons for
that is because of the commercial
Corruption of medicine if you like
perverse incentives
over diagnosis ordering tests that
people don't need in order to make money
so that trust already I think in the
United States amongst doctors certainly
was lower than in the UK because of this
and I think the covert pandemic has only
probably made that worse breath
unfortunately no it uh it clearly has
taken anybody who had trepidations and
Amplified them to a spectacular degree I
really
I I frankly do not know how we rescue
medicine from what it has just done
especially you know what what I'm
watching in the U.S is not only are we
failing to make eye contact
with the harms literally gaslighting
people who have been been vaccine
injured and pretending that we don't
know what's taking place with them
but we are also continuing to do the
harm
right by failing to risk stratify the
population and you know I I agree with
you that these the vaccine campaign
should be halted on the basis of the
Adverse Events
and the uh relatively low danger of the
disease in question also the low
efficacy of uh the the inoculants but
the the idea that we are vaccinating
young people in some cases we are
requiring them to get vaccinated in
order to go to college and that we are
contemplating requiring children of all
people to get these things
um to just simply get an education this
is not a matter of us simply not
recognizing what we've done we're still
doing it and so you know how does any
credibility how is it left over after
that yeah I mean am I wrong that every
cardiologist must know that this is
taking place that their the willful
blindness has to be extreme for them to
avoid it yeah so it's interesting on the
cardiologist stuff um after my papers
are published recently then you know it
was shared amongst many people it's got
a lot of a lot of views a lot of
attention even if it hasn't broken the
mainstream in the UK in the way we
wanted it to but the feedback from
cardiologists has been pretty
extraordinary in terms of them thinking
ah like a light bulb movement thank you
Asim brilliant this makes sense
um I've had feedback from certainly one
cardiologist in a in a well-known
teaching Hospital in London and said
that after reading the paper almost
everybody all the cardiologists are
meeting said we're not having any
boosters
so you know it resonates with them
because again as I said the evidence is
clear I have another hypothesis to throw
in to this discussion as well Brett
which you may have seen on my Twitter I
keep mentioning something called the
psychopathic determinants of health so
if we go further Upstream because what
we're trying to understand also is a
culture you know this is you know if the
medical profession aren't aren't dealing
with this in the way that they should if
we're still trying to mandate coerce
kids to have the vaccine when we're
talking about it being suspended for
everybody how does one explain that and
my hypothesis which I think is based
upon evidence is at the root of the
problem if you go Upstream is that we
have very big powerful corporations in
this case big Pharma who have had
increasing power
over medical decision making over
probably the last couple of decades and
everything really starts from their
behavior so the entity that is the big
Corporation is there predominantly and I
think it's really important to have this
very explicit discussion with people I
tell it to my patients I said they are
there they have a legal or fiduciary
obligation to produce profit for
shareholders not to give you the best
treatment
but the real Scandal is that those who
have a duty to patience and scientific
Integrity Doctors Medical institutions
academic journals collude with industry
for financial gain but the way that the
pharmaceutical industry operates has
been described not by me
by a leader in his field forensic
psychologist Dr Robert Hare he actually
documents that the entity not the
individuals within them we're not we're
not pointing fingers at CEOs of
companies or anything like that but the
way that the drug industry operates is
essentially akin to a psychopath you can
compare it to Psychopathic Behavior so
callus this concern for the feelings of
others deceiving people for profit you
know these are typical behaviors that
there's a short record
um of course one great example I know we
mentioned it before we start the podcast
is around biox and what happened there
and actually if you look back and and
you understand that the you know Merck
new those scientists internal scientists
knew that it was going to cause an
increase in heart attacks but it didn't
it didn't bother them from the company
perspective because they knew they were
going to make a lot of money so you know
the only way to describe this type of
behavior in my view is psychopathic so
actually I think you know maybe we need
to change the narrative in terms of
explaining the culture in many in in
what's going on in health right now as
being a downstream effect of an entity
that behaves that is anti-human that is
anti-democratic that suppresses free
speech that suppresses Freedom of
Information and we can apply all of that
to what's happened during the rollout of
the code vaccine uh which I again I um
elaborate on in my paper
yeah I I resonate with a lot of that and
uh in some sense we've landed in my area
of specialty as an evolutionary
biologist I can tell you exactly what
happened which is our system of laws
surrounding corporate behavior is
basically a niche it describes a niche
and what has happened is that any
corporation that didn't start out
Psychopathic has evolved into and
effectively Psychopathic entity because
it couldn't compete otherwise and so it
really shouldn't be any surprise to us
at all that this is the kind of behavior
the shocking indifference is our failure
as human beings we extrapolate we over
extrapolate our own internal experience
and we project it onto these
corporations because of course when we
encounter them we encounter them in a
human form that's describing what
they're doing
but you know of course they're
Psychopaths right
um if they weren't they would have uh
failed in business so they evolved into
them
um and this does explain not only uh you
know vioxx but a basically General
systematic enlarging of loopholes I mean
effectively you've got an industry
that plays a particular game I call it
the Pharma game and you tell me if this
matches your understanding but the
Pharma game
involves owning various
pieces of intellectual property
finding conditions to which one of these
pieces of intellectual property can be
plausibly linked
broadening the diagnosable
characteristics so that the maximum
number of people are thought to have the
condition
applying these pieces of intellectual
property essentially Pharmaceuticals you
know compounds or treatments that are
highly profitable and then ignoring or
systematically obscuring any harms that
might emerge as a result I mean that's
the winning strategy and
one of my if you know there's it's very
easy to imagine
all sorts of conspiratorial things
happening in the case of covid the the
harms are so shocking that one uh you
know struggles to imagine what the
conversations inside of Pharma sounded
like but
um the shallow end of the pool
sounds like this Pharma has captured our
governmental structures it corrupts them
365 days a year as a matter of Simply
doing business and when covet arrived
there was no mechanism for recognizing
it as anything different than a huge
business opportunity so it steered Us in
this direction because it's doing that
all the time over hundreds of different
compounds and conditions that's just
simply what it does that's what it is
absolutely I think that's summed up very
very well
um that's exactly what they do um their
incentive I I um debated at the
Cambridge Union a few years ago the CEO
of AstraZeneca and the motion that was
put forward is that that we need more
people taking more drugs that was
obviously the motion put forward by them
and I post it and um of course that
would be the ideal scenario for them to
get as many people as possible on as
many drugs as possible and exploit their
their legal entity that they they
um function under
to be able to do that and I think if
we're going to combat this as well
ultimately
Brett it needs changes in the law you
know these laws themselves that allow
them to do this are clearly not
Democratic they're not just they're not
ethical
um and therefore
um what we need is really uh citizens to
become aware and of course you know one
of the ways of disseminating such
information is through mainstream media
and then it puts pressure on politicians
but to paraphrase Noam Chomsky
um you know the um doctors and patients
don't know what's happening and they
don't even know that they don't know so
the reason I mentioned that I'll give
you an example of
um ignorance of this problem these
structural failures at the very highest
level a couple of months ago I gave a
talk at one of the meetings organized
during the conference of the British
Medical Association I had um very senior
medical establishment figures there the
chairman of the British Medical
Association the president of the British
Medical Association
and in that talk I talked about the
corporate capture of medicine and public
health that was essentially the type
talk title
and during the talk I mentioned failure
of the regulator to do its job properly
and I said that the mhra in our country
the medical health and Regulatory agency
receives most of its funding 86 from the
pharmaceutical industry the chairman of
the VMA didn't believe it he was
gobsmacked you know he would he he
looked around and said is this true of
course you know ignorance of these
structural failures are even at the very
highest level Rachelle wolenski you
remember quite um you may remember her
commenting about the fact that her
optimism from the vaccine came from a
CNN news report so the media has a huge
role to play and I know from Paul
Thacker investigative journalist he did
a Blog on this that that original CNN
news report was reported on the
so-called efficacy of the vaccine was
almost verbatim a reproduction of
Pfizer's press release you really
couldn't make it up Brett you really
couldn't make it up
so um the the I think the understanding
acceptance of the these entities and how
they function is one thing but I think
what people need to realize is that The
Regulators themselves the people that
are supposed to be filtering this
information and
you know uh protecting the public from
these so-called excesses and
manipulations of Industry are actually
themselves captured by industry
universities certainly in this country
over the last 20 to 30 years have more
and more funding from the drug industry
uh most of their funding for research
comes from the drug industry now they
are universities are supposed to be
Guardians of the truth and represent the
moral conscience of society but how can
they represent the moral conscience of
society when they are being influenced
and controlled by an immoral entity
what's going to happen it doesn't take a
rocket scientist to figure out that's
going to have a hugely negative impact
on society
yeah there's you know trying to do
anything about it without changing the
law is a little bit like taking the
water in your glass and trying to shove
it over to one side and the answer is no
no it's going to fill the glass that's
what it does and we've got a niche and
these entities are going to operate
within that Niche and become adapted to
it the only solution involves changing
the niche now of course
that is almost impossible to do because
frankly buying political influence in
the west is inexpensive when you're
making the kind of money that they're
making it's just the cost of doing
business and so you know my hope is that
the horror of what we've done
surrounding covid would wake people up
would embarrass them into having to
change laws even though there was a
financial incentive for not doing it but
so far I have not seen evidence of that
yeah bro I agree with you I think in in
some ways we have to we have to use this
crisis
uh and and turn it into an opportunity
for good
and I think I'm with you I think this
will be the Tipping Point I think that I
think we're not far off the bubble
bursting breath to be honest I think
more and more people are becoming aware
and
um and the more that they the more that
do they become you know advocates for
the movement to say this is not
acceptable and and we are angry about
this and we are going to hold people
accountable for this
and that movement is growing every day
Brett and it will reach a Tipping Point
I have no doubt but we obviously as
advocates for the truth uh we can't be
complacent we need to keep making noise
uh and of course I even this
conversation I'm sure in itself will
have its own ripple effect in helping
that change happen
it will uh I will point to I mean
obviously this is one of the messages of
your terrible story
um but the fact of
the injuries from these therapies being
so common
means that many people are going to be
touched
quite directly this is not an abstract
question for an increasing number of
people I will say that even
in my friend group
I can I know off the top of my head two
other stories where people that I know
well enough to have shared a meal with
them have lost fathers
do I know for certain that this is what
happened I don't but the pattern is
awfully clear
and you know that's before we get to the
many uh very serious but lesser Adverse
Events of which I could list off
a couple dozen
um there it it's it's shocking how many
people are seeing the evidence in in
real time right in front of them in
their own families and friend groups so
that will have a a profound effect
um I think it makes sense in light of
your raising vioxx
my
um
Awakening to the hazard of Pharma
actually did not come in uh modern times
it came from something that happened to
me during my graduate career which many
of my long time uh listeners will will
already know the story but uh it's it
fits so so well in this context that I'm
going to briefly tell it to you my guess
is you don't know it is that right you
don't know I don't know
[Music]
so when I was a young graduate student
um I was working I was an evolutionary
biologist I was in theory I was working
on tent making bats in the neotropics
that was my my uh thesis topic but I
became fascinated by the question of why
creatures like us grow feeble and
inefficient with age why senescence
happens
and in following that thread
I ran into
a quadrant of work actually two of them
one surrounding
cancer and the fact that
in almost every Cancer known the enzyme
telomerase is active
this is an enzyme that elongates a
repetitive sequence at the ends of our
chromosomes and at the same time another
group was working on the fact that the
erosion of our telomeres seems to cause
our cells to stop reproducing and that
this was implicated in our growing uh
decrepit with age
I put these two things together with an
evolutionary theory that already existed
a theory called antagonistic plyotropy
by the great evolutionary biologist
George Williams and I had a very elegant
uh novel description of the mechanism of
human aging and the reason that
selection has tolerated it
but it ran into a problem and the
problem was there was one glaring piece
of evidence that did not fit my uh my
hypothesis
and that glaring piece of evidence was
that mice were known to have Ultra long
telomeres but obviously had very short
lives
their telomeres were in fact 10 times
the length of human telomeres which made
no sense in light of my hypothesis of
what the telomeres were doing that the
telomere erosion was effectively
protecting us from cancers that would
otherwise take us over
well in pursuing that
I teamed up
with Carol Grider one of The Luminaries
in telomere space she is in fact the
co-discoverer of the enzyme telomerase
and I called her up and I told her what
I was thinking and I said is there some
some possible way that we've got it
wrong and that mouth telomeres are not
Ultra long and she said well I think
they are Ultra long but there is
something weird about the telomeres
because if you order a different Mouse
and you order them from Europe then the
length of the telomeres varies
tremendously
um and so anyway she was interested
enough that she started working with her
graduate student and she tested my
hypothesis that wild mice would not have
long telomeres and that in fact it would
be something about the breeding
environment that we raised these mice in
that had elongated their telomeres and
Confused us right and this has profound
implications the most significant of
them
is that these mice are presumably biased
by their Ultra long telomeres in a
couple of different directions one
they're terrifically prone to tumors in
fact one of the things that Carol Grider
told me in our initial phone
conversation was that effectively all
laboratory mice die of tumors if you
give them a chance
so they're very prone to tumors but the
other thing is the reason that they
would be prone to tumors according to to
my hypothesis was that
the tissues that they have have no break
on their capacity for repair and so
these animals are also terrifically
resistant according to this hypothesis
to damage any damage that doesn't
outright kill them is relatively easy
for them to fix
so what that means
is they make terrible models for drug
safety
because you can give them a toxic insult
and in fact we see a very odd result
which is well explained by my hypothesis
which is that if you give them a toxic
drug that does not outright kill them it
may extend their lives because it
functions as chemotherapy slowing down
their tumors
so I don't think Pharma knew if I didn't
say it already in this discussion let me
say that Carol tested the hypothesis
that wild mice have short telomeres and
that in fact what the long telomeres
were an anomaly of the lab environment
and that is what she and her graduate
student Mike Heman established so at
that point I knew that my larger
hypothesis was likely right
now the point though is at the upon
realizing
that the mice that we get all come from
a tiny number of sources in the U.S it's
largely the Jax lab in Bar Harbor Maine
and that these mice have been distorted
by their evolutionary environment in
this way that makes them terrifically
prone to cancer and terrifically
resistant to damage
if you use those mice in a drug safety
test
what you will typically get is a clean
bill of health
now
what that predicts in fact
is exactly what we saw in the vioxx
Scandal
we saw a drug that seemed safe that when
released into humans did damage now
I do differ with the interpretation that
what it does is heart damage
my hypothesis would suggest that what it
does is tissue damage and that we notice
heart damage because the failure of
Hearts is very conspicuous
and when young people die of heart
attacks we notice
so
um
in any case
I think what may have happened is that
Pharma did not know that it had mice
biased in the favor of in favor of its
drugs making them look safe
upon discovering that we had this flaw
in our drug safety system and that in
fact our scientific literature was
polluted by this broken model
I expected there would be
a scandal there would be a rush to fix
the problem
and that we would end up having to
retest many drugs that uh would many of
them would turn out not to be safe but
that you know a few years down the road
we would have uh
gotten back on track
I tried to raise the alarm
for a decade I published my work
I attempted to call the attention of
fellow scientists doctors journalists
it's the Bell that wouldn't ring and to
this day I do not believe we have fixed
this problem what we have done is
obscure it so
the funny thing about this story and the
strange punch line of it is I now see
these mice re-emerge in the recent test
that was the basis for declaring them
safe for children
and you know it's odd I find myself
whistleblower twice over in the same
story you know wow decades apart
um so anyway am I right you've not heard
that story no I haven't it's
extraordinary though and it's
fascinating
it's fascinating uh and in some sense
watching my colleagues completely fail
to take any action upon discovering that
their model was broken in this very
dangerous way alerted me to just how
uh corrupt our system was in other words
lots of careers rested on uh papers that
would be invalidated by uh recognizing
this Hazard there were lots of knockout
mice that had been built on the
background of these uh these distorted
creatures and presumably
that work would be a lot less valuable
if one had to go back and re-knock out
the same gene in the mouse that wasn't
distorted in this way so what I saw I
don't know if it was a conspiracy or
what but I do know that there was
exactly none of the action that you
would expect in light of the discovery
of such a profound hazard
I wonder whether it's related also
because of this model that has been used
for so long Brett
um there's probably a lot of financial
um incentive to continue down this line
as in it would cost them a lot of money
to change tact
is there is there any other reason that
you is that part of the equation as well
well I you know look
um I I have a principle which I have uh
is painfully one which is
no matter how cynical you are you're
still being naive
and in light of that principle I wonder
if either either Pharma knew about the
mice the mouse bias before my work
and I just happened to speak about it in
public
or they didn't but it alerted them to
this and their reaction was exactly what
you would expect the psychopathic
Corporation to be and not what you would
expect a decent human's reaction to be
and the idea is okay how can we obscure
this and utilize it
and so you know again watching them use
a tiny handful of broken mice to
establish the safety of these so-called
vaccines for children looks to me like a
deliberate leveraging of the
accidentally produced Hazard that I
discovered 20 years ago yeah and
I don't know I
I guess the question is is it even
conceivable that upon discovering they
had mice biased in the direction of
suggesting that pharmaceutical
treatments were safe that they would
work to correct the problem
right where's the incentive for them to
do that no no there isn't I mean the
other thing that I found quite
interesting and eye-opening for me is
the
um the use of antibody tests to the that
were generated from the vaccine that the
FDA in May 2021
explicitly on their website said that
you know these antibodies are unreliable
in terms of immunity or protection from
covid-19 especially after having had the
vaccine so clearly they realize that the
antibodies themselves
uh are not very specific in terms of
protecting people from covid-19 which is
really quite interesting because that
seems to be certainly more recently
especially even with the my studies and
other studies they seem to be relying on
the antibody tests
in the trials to suggest that this is an
effective vaccine when they them they're
contradicting themselves
um and uh again this is you know I think
one of the things that is a
a concept or something that I learned in
my campaigning on sugar as an activist
is the the science alone isn't enough
opposition from vested interest needs to
be overcome
well uh I want to fill in a little bit
what you're saying about the antibodies
because I I find it equally shocking the
idea is they've set a standard that is
easy to meet it is not that hard to get
the immune system to respond at the
level of the production of antibodies
but it is a giant and totally
unjustified leap to say that the fact
that you see a bunch of antibodies means
that this will be an effective
preventive measure and in fact
um you know we have a condition called
antibody dependent enhancement in which
the presence of antibodies actually
facilitates the access of a pathogen
into cells so it's not like there are no
cases in which the presence of
antibodies would be negative there
certainly are that's well known
um and it's almost as if
instead of trying to impress
sophisticated Regulators with the safety
and potential Effectiveness as
demonstrate demonstrated in some
reasonable way that what they're really
trying to do is Hoodwink the public
right the public knows Loosely what an
antibody is that it tends to be a
positive force in immunity it doesn't
know the difference between B and T
cells it doesn't understand where the
most useful immunities are likely to be
derived it doesn't know that dealing
with a respiratory virus by injecting
something in your arm is probably not a
good approach in the first place it
doesn't understand anything about
the expected
um locality of these vaccines where the
immunity was supposed to be generated it
wasn't supposed to be circulating around
your body and absorbed by tissues uh
haphazardly that was never the design or
if it was then that's criminal because
you know the the simple fact of inducing
a cell of yours to manufacture a foreign
protein is essentially certain to call
the attention of the T cells and cause
them to destroy the cells in question
which if it's a small number of cells in
your liver
might be a very minor matter if it's
cells in your heart it's a disaster
right
you know and as I've said on this
podcast multiple times
these transfection agents are a
technological Marvel it's really an
incredibly it's a it's a potentially
very valuable Innovation but there is no
way these things were ready for
injecting into human beings right this
is a prototype and they tried to
vaccinate everybody on Earth with it and
that's unconscionable right we should be
celebrating these things uh in the
academic literature and we should be
trying to figure out how they might be
properly targeted so that they don't
cause the immune system to attack cells
throughout the body
but we skipped all that we just decided
they were safe and effective almost by
decree and went around injecting people
irrespective of their need for them
which you know yeah and what I find even
more shocking Brett is even once this
information was clearly available that
there was a signal of harm they didn't
just carry on with the rollout they
coerced and mandated it I mean that is
just beyond belief that can only be
described as being rooted in psychopathy
as far as I'm concerned there's only
there's no other explanation
it not only that but the protections
from such a thing are utterly specific
hard one gains at the end of the
Holocaust we went through the effort of
writing the Nuremberg code and
establishing the absoluteness of one's
right to informed consent
and in this case we have proprietary
ingredient lists we have uh adverse
event signals which are being
systematically ignored there's no way
patients are deciding to take these
things on the basis of information and
what's more once you coerce them then
it's not consent so we're violating
we're violating Nuremberg
out in the open and that my sense is
look anytime you're violating Nuremberg
something important is going on and it
ought to call the attention of anybody
who takes the idea of civilization
seriously in the first place
this is one of the things we don't do
informed consent is as close to sacred
as we get
absolutely and we're not going to
improve you know that one of the things
I'm a big proponent of is is
evidence-based medicine and there's a
very elegant analytical and teaching
framework we use to practice
evidence-based medicine and that
incorporates our individual clinical
expertise as a doctor the best available
evidence and then last but not least is
taking into consideration individual
patient preferences and values and at
the heart of that is share this is
making informed consent and if you don't
incorporate those three components then
you are not going to achieve
um in the you know uh optimal patient
outcomes
you know treating an illness managing
risks reducing suffering and actually
everything to be honest for me um I
think comes back to our doctors actually
practicing
evidence-based medicine in in order to
ethical evidence-based medicine
to improve patient outcomes and I think
many unwittingly are not I think most
doctors want to do the right thing they
go into profession for those reasons
um but they are being deceived by this
powerful corporate entity and um uh and
then and then you know again doesn't
take a rocket scientist to figure out if
you're making clinical decisions on
biased and corrupted information Brett
they're best you're going to get some
optimal outcomes for the patient the
worse you're going to do harm
so actually in a way the solutions are
quite simple
you know from an intellectual point of
view they're not complicated they're
very simple but um those Solutions those
Simple Solutions are a challenge to uh
the profit making you know businesses of
uh of um of these multinational
corporations
well I I agree with that I will tell you
um I would have told you three weeks ago
that I was a strong proponent of
evidence-based medicine and then I read
a piece written by a good friend of mine
alexandros marinos on evidence-based
medicine which alerted me to some things
I didn't know about it anyway I'd be
interested you you don't happen to have
read the piece do you I I haven't read
the piece Bob cures to to know a little
bit more about it yeah well I'd be happy
to send it to you and I'll post a link
in the description of this video so
other people can read it you know what I
hear you describing is obviously what we
should be doing it's what I thought
evidence-based medicine was and it you
know focuses in large measure on the
experience of the clinician which is
something that was bypassed in the case
of covid in a very extreme
extreme way
um
but
I guess you know I I had a conversation
with Pierre Corey uh
I can't remember exactly when it was it
was one of the ones that YouTube took
down before demonetizing this channel
um and anyway we talked about the shift
that once upon a time doctors were
inherently scientists they had fewer
tools at their disposal but what they
did have was the ability to see patterns
in their community in an individual
patient over time and that extrapolating
from those patterns to a proper course
of treatment you know trying things that
would seem like they should work
discovering that they do or don't and
you know building up a protocol based on
the actual impact on patients makes a
tremendous amount of sense and what what
has happened and what went into
overdrive during covid seems to have
been this idea that medicine is about
proclamations from on high handed down
and administered by doctors it's
effectively turned them into
uh technicians Downstream of a an opaque
process and it's almost impossible for
me to imagine how that could go right
yes I think another way of describing is
that evidence-based medicine has been
hijacked or it's become an illusion
because that other component which I
didn't discuss in detail is this best
available evidence certainly over the
years seems to have become more and more
distorted and biased and you know to
cite John ainidis who you know is
Professor of medicine at Stanford and
probably one of the smartest guys on the
planet as a medical scientist
um you know he published a paper in plus
one in 2001 I think which was why most
published research findings are false
yeah um and and you know if one starts
from that position understanding what
all the biases are in terms of
um you know the best available evidence
then it's easier to understand why we're
not getting good patient outcomes or the
best patient outcomes but also the
solutions are there you know and
ultimately the solutions mean Brett the
the drug industry although they can
develop drugs or devices or whatever
else
they shouldn't be allowed to test them
and they shouldn't be allowed to then
hold on to the data because that's
really where the the heart of the
problem lies in clinical decision making
they design the trials they rig the
trials they do their own analyzes they
um Co-op scientists you know they fund
institutions and and and all of that
ultimately results in what you described
earlier on is that we all get an
exaggeration
on the benefits and safety of
medications
um you know I would say that people the
default position needs to be now this
all industry sponsored studies need to
be seen as marketing until proven
otherwise
so I wanted to call attention to
something else that I I hear in your
description of what's taken place and I
uh I've also been tracking it separately
in my own life and work
which is a disconnect between
the short term implications of things
and the long term and I find that in a
regulatory sense
when we are good we are good at spotting
short-term connections that are very
direct
and we often over extrapolate to the
long term and we you know for example
you point out was the number one in 800
serious adverse event risk in the
randomized controlled trials
but that one in 800 is
over a tiny number of months two months
so there is no if one has the sense that
okay one in 800 that's bad but it's not
catastrophic that we have no idea what
fraction of people were injured from
that trial in the long run and what's
more
uh our ability to discover it is
obscured by another little feature of
the Pharma game
Pharma loves to trigger a an ethical
provision
in the uh in the protocols which says
that if a drug is sufficiently
efficacious in a trial it is immoral not
to give it to those in the control group
and so if it can arrange to hit that
Mark then it can obliterate the control
group and make it impossible to figure
out what the long-term impact of these
treatments is because in fact the
control group only existed for a short
period of time
so I guess
um you know this this is the thing that
stuck out for Heather and me at the
beginning of this was even if these
things are highly effective at
preventing the transmission of covid
which they turned out not to be there is
the danger that they will create harms
10 years down the road which we will be
completely unaware of until those
patterns emerge and
um that's always the case we always have
to be cautious that what we are doing is
on the basis of comparatively short time
series and our information gets better
over time but only if we collect the
data yeah Brad no 100 I'm glad you've
raised this point so I think that 1 800
figure is probably a significant
underestimate of the true serious
Adverse Events because that was really
only in the first two months and then
they you know they then um unblinded
people in the control group now one of
what could also be the case historically
well well a couple of things one is
when these trials are designed it's in
Farmers interest to try and show that
the safety is
as best as it can possibly be through
the trial and often that means that they
will recruit people who are probably
lower risk of having Adverse Events
because they know they figured stuff out
early on whether it's through animal
studies or whatever else who is likely
to be least likely to develop a
significant adverse effect so that we
have to throw into the equation as well
then you've got what as you've suggested
what could be going on further down the
line
expand certainly I think there is more
than enough evidence now to suggest from
a coronary artery disease perspective
and I by the way manage patients as well
who have had a rapid acceleration of
coronary artery disease where we've done
corneannigrams routinely and suddenly a
mild narrowing within the space of nine
months or a year suddenly severe which
doesn't happen usually that quickly and
the only common denominator is two doses
of Pfizer or moderna vaccine right so
it's accelerating one of the mechanisms
is it's accelerating accelerating
carniotic disease which means and this
seems to happen you know quite quickly
within the first few months we will
probably continue to see a rise in
people having heart attacks or being
diagnosed with ischemic heart disease
for years because of this
um and therefore and even Cardiac Arrest
my father for example
he wouldn't have been picked up in the
trial because and I must add that my
case study or description of what
happened to my dad was in the
peer-reviewed paper which was then
accepted by the peer reviewers as well
as a reasonable explanation for what
happened to him my father had his
cardiac arrest six months after the
second dose of the fisa vaccine
and I described that as a case study and
I said that this these are type of case
studies that would often you know would
be it's it's a way of explaining complex
information that may be missed from a
randomized control trial so here's an
example of that and other patients I've
seen as well
um certainly
um can have effects you know a few
months after the vaccine which which
through the history seemed to ultimately
be attributed to the vaccine so I think
um it's probably a gross underestimate I
think the other thing that's worth
mentioning historically with
pharmacovigilance data
um it's thought that a serious Adverse
Events are reported
are actually only uh um represent about
10 of the true cases
and Norway have been pretty good at
looking at their recoverment of vars or
the other card scheme and they found
certainly early on
um what constituted uh whether there was
a doctor entry for a serious adverse
event which was very clearly defined as
something that was life-changing or
resulted in hospitalization or
disability that was about one in 926.
after two doses of the fisa vaccine
so that could again probably that's
still an underestimate of what's going
on because many conditions and certain
things that are going on in the
community that are serious would not
come out through the reporting scheme
and therefore I think it's much much
worse
yeah much much worse is uh
is essentially certain I mean you know
as you point out your father would not
have been counted as an adverse event uh
because he would have been long after
the trial was over and
um so we have to ask ourselves
how many of these things are being
captured at all and to the extent that
we have a completely unprecedented
um signal in these and so I think one of
the thing that we've talked about
informed consent and and something I
wanted to highlight in my paper is that
if we if we accept the least uh of the
risk of a serious adverse event let's
just say is one in 800 probably that's
an underestimate what's the benefit and
what I try to do using actual real world
data looking at hospitalization and
deaths in the UK during the Delta wave
last year
was to break down by age group and by
the way this is not corrected for
confounding factors so we know for
example unvaccinated certainly the UK
and maybe in the US tend to come from
low socioeconomic groups and are
generally higher risk of death from
covert anyway so this is still best case
scenario but what we found is if you're
over 80
um the vaccine during a wave during the
Delta wave the vaccine um would give you
a benefit of 1 in 230 in terms of
preventing a covert death it became one
in 520 if you're aged between 70 and 80
but during Omicron
you know from the first few months this
year you're talking about having to
vaccinate 7 300 people over the age of
80.
to prevent one covered death
and you know that is a number when I
tell patients that
you know I I've I do this in my practice
when I discuss other pills like statin
drugs for example
most of those patients would say no
thank you Doctor that's not for me right
yeah we try and introduce informed
consent with the best available evidence
most people would not take uh certainly
anymore would not take this vaccine
yeah it's a slam dunk if you're talking
about needing to
inoculate 7 000 people with a substance
that causes a serious adverse event in
one in 800 inside of two months with no
information on how many people are
ultimately impacted you know many months
down the road where the connection uh
may be lost then that is you know
obviously medically counter-indicated
um
uh so yeah it's and you know the certain
things stick out about this program this
is clearly not epidemiological or
medical in nature because if it was
you would Age stratify the
recommendation
right now again I don't think either you
or I think anybody should be getting
these mRNA inoculants
um but if you were let's say that you
calculated differently you would still
think the older you were the more likely
you were to get a benefit that could
justify facing the risks and there's no
way you'd be pointing them at children
but the fact is
we've got some sort of cartoon policy in
which inoculation good you know that
that's basically the point and
um
uh it's not surprising the Pharma would
take that perspective what is
maybe somewhat more surprising is that
our Public Health officials would but of
course as you point out the degree to
which their funding is coming from
exactly the people who benefit from such
a policy makes that less surprising
the fact that
the trials are run by the companies that
have this perverse incentive is of
course a jaw-dropping discovery but then
there's even one layer deeper I wonder
what uh if you have thoughts on this
what I learned in uh looking at the RCT
data and evidence from
uh from Pharma was that in fact it's not
even that these companies do the trials
the companies contract the trials to
these companies that run trials as their
business
and the problem with that is that that
constitutes another evolutionary
environment in other words if if the
client is a Pharma company
trying to find out if a drug is safe
enough to administer
well then there's competition between
the uh companies that run the trials to
deliver evidence of safety
they know that because the point is a
drug company doesn't want to spend the
money to test a drug that isn't safe
enough to bring to Market so the desired
answer is clear and all they have to do
is Select for companies that tend to
give them an indicator of safety and the
point is that little industry of people
who run trials for a living
evolves in the direction of finding
safety no matter what the truth is right
it's you can see the psychopathy
evolving you know almost in real time
yeah no it makes sense I hadn't thought
about it from that perspective
and Brett makes complete sense no doubt
if we were to just simply probe the
system in location after location we
would find little surprises like that
that one happens to have become clear in
those cases but how many other places
are there where the system is subtly
biased in the direction of giving us an
indication that drugs are more effective
than they actually are that competitors
are less effective than they actually
are that the drugs are safer than they
actually are right the point is the
whole system is looking for ways to sell
that story and you know I mean you said
it yourself uh you know 20 minutes ago
that effectively any of the stuff
produced by the system should be taken
as uh as PR yeah right as PR it's not
science science is
a delicate process that requires you to
actually adhere to the the method and
the underlying philosophy of science and
the perverse it's not robust to perverse
incentives the fact is science requires
you to to actually do it properly
yeah and I think the other thing as well
there's a myth that needs to be busted
amongst many people I think that still
exists out there and pervades across
um you know many societies across the
world is that medicine is an exact
science and it's not an exact science I
say physics or chemistry it's an applied
science it's a science of human beings
human beings are complex human beings
are Dynamic and you know one of the
things we're taught in medical school is
that 50 of what you learn will turn out
to be either outdated or dead wrong
within five years of your graduation the
trouble is nobody can tell you which
half
so you have to learn to learn on your
own and I think one of the interesting
things I noticed during this whole
pandemic which concerned me is Anthony
fauci coming out consistently saying
trusts of science
that's probably one of the most
unscientific statements I've ever heard
in my life
Anthony saying that it doesn't make any
sense it's nonsense there's always an
uncertainty attached to this stuff
things change and evolve and it was this
was um but I think that was exploitation
of people's false beliefs of what modern
medicine does and what modern medicine
can achieve and you know there's no
doubt that mod we've achieved many great
things certainly in acute care
but if you look back over the last
couple of decades
um Brett you know we know for example
from analysis by
um Marcia Angel former editor of
neogenic medicine uh between 2000 2008
of the 667 drugs approved by the FDA on
the 11 were found to be truly Innovative
75 were essentially copies of old ones
we've had certainly in the UK and I
think that it's similar in the US it may
even be getting worse we've had a
stalling and life expectancy for the
last decade
combined with an increasing burden of
chronic disease so people are living
longer in sickness so that in itself
should be an indication that there's
clearly something wrong with the medical
system and at the heart of that is this
over-medicated population and lack of
attention to
the simple stuff which is actually
leading a healthy life through lifestyle
um you know good health doesn't we need
to just we need to get this message into
the minds of the American public good
health does not come out of a medicine
bottle
um yeah you this is uh
beautifully said and fits so perfectly
with uh The evolutionary implications
right and you know you you quite
correctly diagnose the problem and I
what the argument I've made is that we
inferred the rules of science from the
simple Sciences from the fundamental
Sciences chemistry and physics because
that's where our big early gains came
and we've misunderstood how to apply it
in the context of a complex system it
doesn't work right if you take the
approach as if it was a simple system
and you might well have the idea that oh
this person has a pathology the obvious
thing to do is to apply a compound that
interfaces with the particular pathway
in which that pathology emerges but you
know if you do that how many other
things are you interfering with right
the chances that you're going to do that
at low cost are actually surprisingly
low and the right way to deal with these
things is almost always to figure out
what the um what the source of the issue
is and to correct what you're calling
the lifestyle issue that causes it now
sometimes it's too late and sometimes
you got to take a drug to you know
basically it functions like a corrective
lens but
um but the long and short of it is
Pharma has a perverse incentive to get
us to take more drugs and to think that
that's normal
and not only are is the human being a
complex system but it's a nested series
of complex systems you know in the case
of covid you were dealing with uh the
immune system which is a complex system
of its own inside a human being another
complex system inside a society in which
an epidemic is taking place a third
complex that's a nested series of
complex systems the chances of
intervening and you know coming out way
ahead are pretty low
and the chances of your coming out way
ahead if what you do is you intervene on
the basis of some simplistic conclusion
and then you don't track the impact of
it you know the chances are essentially
zero
right that was that was going to be a
disaster just from the get-go
and uh yeah
the uh sorry to lay that on you and then
switch gears a little bit but I did uh
want to ask you about this I saw an
interview actually Steven Crowder
uh Canadian comedian had a mortician on
did you happen to see that interview I
I'm not no I'm not familiar with that
one well he had a mortician on and the
mortician was reporting that he is now
seeing these uh huge growth he actually
showed them he has captured a number of
them these huge growths from the
arteries of recently deceased people
they are apparently anomalous in his
experience he hasn't seen these things
before they superficially might be
called clots but they are chemically uh
not similar to what a normal not only is
the structure much larger in fact he
tells the story that he thought his the
pump that profuses corpses with
formaldehyde was broken because it
couldn't push past these clots and when
he went after them he got these
gargantuan uh Alien looking things out
of people's
arteries I was wondering
um if you have heard anything like this
from the medical side no Dr Drew
actually mentioned this as well to me
and I've seen a few of these images but
um and they look very extraordinary and
nothing like I've seen before I haven't
um personally had anyone contact me or
any pathologist to suggest to me that
they've seen anything like this it
doesn't mean it's not happening
um but yeah I mean you know this is
again a novel technology and and we
don't know exactly all the kind of
things it's doing within the body and
certainly clotting abnormalities
themselves and it may be these are
unusual you know they have unusual
appearance are one of the most common
um serious Adverse Events from the
vaccine so Joseph Freeman who's a lead
author on that paper
published in vaccine where they did a
re-analysis and found this one in 800
figure he told me that actually within
that 1 800 figure 40 the most common
serious adverse event was related to
clotting so including things like heart
attack Strokes Pomme emboli so that's an
interesting you know um what you've
shared with me probably fits with that
but I don't know yeah I wouldn't be able
to comment on on the specific pathology
yeah
um you raise another issue though you
know a you know I don't know anything
about it professionally but
um these pseudo collapse or whatever
they are or maybe they are clots look to
like they must have accumulated over a
very long period of time and I'd be very
curious to know if that's true whether
they show up on scans this kind of thing
but the other issue is
you know another little place where the
Pharma game Alters our perception
is that there are claims about well you
know what is the commonality of
myocardinis following a second uh dose
of Pfizer for example well
that is not a good question because
myocarditis is diagnosed at some
threshold right presumably there's lots
of subclinical myocarditis maybe there's
even undetectable myocarditis and this
is not liable to be cost free in terms
of your longevity for example right so
if you have a little myocarditis not
enough to cause you to seek medical
attention
and then at some point in the future you
push your system Beyond some usual limit
maybe that turns into a critical
failure and won't be attributed to uh
the the cause from the so-called
vaccines and so I guess I'm I'm
wondering to what extent do you think
our crude measurement tools are missing
damage that will actually be significant
enough
um to alter longevity I think that they
are missing them to a large degree
breadth so I've managed many people in
the community who would not have had a
formal diagnosis of myocarditis because
of the vaccine because they develop
symptoms in the community that they
didn't Merit as being severe enough to
be hospitalized but clinically from the
history you could say it probably was
myopericarditis where you get
involvement of the outer layer of the
heart as well and that gives people
chest pain and they were very classic
one of my patients a lady in her 50s
actually developed
um within a cup two months of having the
vaccine very fit and well good no
problems in the background round
shortness of breath and then
echocardiogram an ultrasound scan of the
heart revealed that a heart muscle pump
function was severely impaired and again
from the history the most likely cause
was the vaccine
she again wasn't admit to hospital so I
suspect was probably probably quite a
lot of people out there that uh that are
you know who are vaccine damaged maybe
don't know it or certainly aren't coming
under the statistics in the published
literature of say one in 2700 I think
that's the highest figure reported in
young males of prevalence of myocarditis
after the vaccine but that's
specifically people who were
hospitalized so you're right it's
probably a lot of people in the
community who are having vaccine damage
as well and again how this plays out in
the long term we really don't know but
if there is any Scar in The myocardium
which often happens after myocarditis
then that could be a potential substrate
for rhythm disorders moving forward I
think one of the other things that's
worth mentioning as well Brett in terms
of you know I try first and foremost me
as a doctor as a physician is I want to
be the best possible doctor I can be for
my patient and there are two crucial
components to being a good doctor or
getting the best patient out comes one
is your history taking your clinical
history taking and the other is empathy
and the reason why history taking is
important is that eighty percent of your
diagnoses comes from the discussion with
a patient if you are a good doctor a
good doctor doesn't rely on tests or go
to test first a good doctor makes his
diagnosis predominantly or likely
diagnosis from the discussion and that's
really how um you know the the and that
concept interestingly a little anecdote
for you here my alma mater is University
of Edinburgh
the University of Edinburgh Medical
School was also
um they was known well known also
because one of its medical students
became a doctor was Arthur Conan Doyle
who is the author of Sherlock Holmes and
I are you aware of the link between
Sherlock Holmes and Medicine Brett do
you know about this story I don't think
so
so Sherlock Holmes's byline was this
and this is how he solved his murder
mysteries his you know who perpetrated
crimes and I say this is how we make
diagnosis
when you've eliminated the impossible
whatever remains
however improbable must be true
and if you if you apply that to Medical
Practice you'll never miss a diagnosis
the problem we've got certainly in
relation to the covert vaccine is that
doctors are not even conceiving of the
possibility that many of these problems
are related to the vaccine because
industry has hidden that data and
therefore it's not part of the
differential diagnosis once I became
aware of these possibilities from a who
World Health Organization endorsed list
of all these potential side effects
which again I list in in my paper then
you open your mind up to the possibility
that the vaccine could be a cause
because you've excluded other possible
causes so many people who are being
gaslighted or being told it can't be the
vaccine but they're being told I don't
have any explanation for why you will
know risk factors suddenly had a heart
attack or why you've not had a history
of a viral infection you've suddenly
presented with heart failure you know
the common denominator through the
history often is the vaccine and that's
how you make the diagnosis
a couple things in there worthy of
comment
um one is the rush to vaccinate
everybody complicates this if they had
succeeded in vaccinating everybody then
it obscures part of the pattern because
doctors wouldn't be able to detect some
difference between their vaccinated and
unvaccinated patients
um
but the
the other thing is that there's
obviously a booby trap that has been
installed in many of our minds where
because of the what I now regard as the
Absurd portrayal of anti-vaxxers as a
simple
monolithic phenomenon many of us have
difficulty
wrapping our minds around the
possibility that something that we've
been told as a vaccine could possibly be
doing massive levels of harm which is
absurd because obviously many vaccines
uh have not gotten past trials on the
basis that safety signals emerged others
have been pulled from the market after
Adverse Events
uh signals showed that they were unsafe
so they're not inherently Safe products
um and I think it took many of us some
time to get past the idea that
effectively
anti-vaxxers Were Free Riders who were
getting the benefit of other people's
taking a small risk and being vaccinated
they were getting the benefit of those
people's immunity which in fact is I'm
certain a part of the phenomenon but
others had legitimate concerns
which frankly aren't easily dismissed in
one Fell Swoop
yes completely I think what's
interesting is people have asked me why
did you you know you've been a big
critic and skeptic of drug industry why
did you take the vaccine at the
beginning and of course it was
complicated reasons for me personally
both on a personal level but also on the
fact that I I can you know I'm not a
vaccine expert and I didn't even predict
or expect this would happen
um but uh I think that
um
you know
what I would say certainly is that many
people at the beginning Brett
I would say didn't take the vaccine for
irrational reasons
and the people who are now deciding they
don't want boosters or whatever else so
many of them are not taking it for
rational reasons because some of those
original thoughts around the vaccine
okay we don't know the long-term effects
but then we don't know the long-term
effects of many things right at the
beginning we didn't really have very
strong data at the very beginning on the
harm certainly not high quality data
so a lot of that was maybe intuition it
could be
um people uh were buying into
things that really are quite ridiculous
I think such as it's part of a
depopulation agenda there are microchips
in the vaccine many of the people who
didn't take it were taking it you know
not taking it for those reasons
so
um I I don't think certainly for me as a
cardiologist
although I could have been more
skeptical and taken longer to make a
personal decision on it I wouldn't have
been able to have the data that I was
able to produce in that paper a couple
of months ago I didn't have that data at
my disposal at the very beginning to to
make a very clear decision that this
vaccine is going to cause significant
harm and doesn't have much benefit we
didn't it took time for us to gather
that information
it did although you know I came at this
from a different route I knew full well
that there was a problem with Pharma I
knew that if I opened because of the
experience with with mouse telomeres I
know that when I opened my medicine
cabinet I see a a bunch of question
marks and even as somebody who's well
informed about the issue I'm in no
position to say which of those question
marks are
um filled in with a hazard I can't see
and which of those you know pills might
be safe
so you know I was on alert but I think
the larger you know there's a question
about what you call
irrational
now the microchip
uh allegation is irrational it's
counter-rational I believe
um on the other hand
I don't feel that way about somebody who
decided not to take it on the basis that
they are aware that our system is
corrupt and therefore what they're being
told about safety May well not be true
that is it's kind of meta rationality
that's rational no that's rational
absolutely yeah so okay good I'm glad
we're we're aligned actually
interestingly when I went on Good
Morning Britain I actually addressed it
I said there were rational and
irrational concerns about the vaccine I
said the rational concerns are exactly
what you said Brett uh because let's
look at the history of Pharma you know
their business model is fraud and this
is what they've done you know they they
are we've got an issue of the third most
common cause of death after heart
disease and cancer
um I'll prescribed medications and that
is rooted in Pharma corruption so I said
that's completely rational absolutely
yeah it is irrational I will say it's an
interesting pattern that I've noticed
among the coveted dissidents you
included uh is how many of the coveted
dissidents are in fact uh inoculated
with these vaccines for covet 19.
um so even people who were well
positioned to see it
uh the the ramping up of the campaign
was so rapid and the messaging was so
black and white that I think even people
who were primed to be able to detect it
got caught off guard yeah and I think
that for me was when when things turned
for me is when they suddenly when I
started looking obviously the potential
homes but when they turned it into
mandate and I say ramping up the
campaign then I knew that we there was a
problem I knew there was an issue and
certainly I knew then it was more about
profit than protecting people right and
that's when you know I campaigned and I
did help to some degree I was a very
prominent campaigner to get the vaccine
mandate overturned for National Health
Service staff I spent months you know
both in mainstream media and behind the
scenes making that happen so
um I knew that that was taking things
way too far absolutely and then and then
the final point I think um as well
um Brett is I find it very difficult to
believe
the Pfizer scientists didn't know by the
end of their randomized control trial
before the drug was approved
that this was going to cause significant
harm to many people and I wonder is that
why they were so strong in getting
indemnification from governments against
um you know being liable if uh if there
were you know vaccine injuries
which means if that is correct Brett
it should never have been approved in
the first place should never have been
approved and you know one piece of
evidence uh that is suggestive you're
right about this is that the discovery
after they were released about how much
harm they do hasn't changed things a bit
from the perspective of you know Pharma
has not become cautious over them so
there's no reason to think that they
learned about those harms late since it
didn't change their trajectory at all oh
yeah well well a psychopathic entity
won't change right they have to be
forced to be they have to be forced into
into a position where
um you know they are made accountable
it's quite right
um uh two final things from my side
you're welcome to enter anything in the
discussion that you want to
um are you concerned for yourself having
gotten a double dose of the Pfizer
vaccine
great question
um
I think that
I'm an optimist I think that certainly
from what we've seen most of the serious
Adverse Events tend to happen early on
of course with the exception maybe of
cardioactive disease progressing Etc and
people already have underlying coronary
artery disease
um
I am
I think there's wishful thinking I'm
hopeful that I'm probably okay and I
think most people should also feel that
way but the honest answer Brett is we
don't know
but what what good is that going to do I
think psychologically worrying about
something that hasn't happened
um isn't of any benefit right now in the
same way that we don't worry we
shouldn't we're all gonna die
so why worry about death you know
um when it when it's not something
that's imminent why worry about it well
I am a uh a fan it's my own invention so
maybe I'm not a fan but I am uh
personally I advocate for what I call
adaptive dwelling which is to say you
should dwell on something exactly to the
point that dwelling on it further
doesn't do you any good at which point
you should abandon it and what I would
say is there's one way in which I think
a little bit of dwelling is probably
valuable and believe me I don't want
people worried about something that's in
the past and can't be undone what I do
want people to understand which I
suspect is not it's not well known in
public
is that this is not the place for a well
I'm already vaccinated what can I do
style of analysis the point is they're
continuing to push boosters on people
and new versions and everything I
understand about this suggests that the
risk through one of a couple different
mechanisms and maybe they're both in
play
the risk is likely to be cumulative
we've seen that to some extent in the
data but at the very least maybe you got
away with it if you got away with it
keep yourself as safe from this stuff as
you can absolutely yeah no more and I
think also obviously my duty and
responsibility as an advocate and a
doctor is to make sure no further harm
happens to anybody else so that's why I
was so strong on this because people
would say to you know some people will
say well hold on your dad died what can
you do you can't bring him back I said
hold on my responsibility is to make
sure that doesn't happen to anybody else
I think the other thing as well that
people can think about Brett is it it
does appear certainly that certainly
with covet and even maybe with the
vaccine the people who are most
vulnerable to side effects are people
who are already in poor metabolic health
so they have conditions relation related
to excess body fat so one of the things
that people can do certainly is just get
themselves in better shape because if
these effects are pro-inflammatory and
related to conditions like heart disease
your best counter is to Institute
lifestyle changes that are going to
mitigate or minimize those risks and I
think that's something that people can
proactively do that's something I I
follow my own advice
um and certainly some of my patients
with long covid have got significantly
better once they've lost weight they've
improved their diet and their symptoms
have improved so I think we should all
focus on making sure our Baseline has
health is as best as possible as it can
be and maybe one of the downstream or
maybe one of the effects of all of this
so I mean something I highlighted very
um I was very vocal on at the beginning
of the pandemic um you know highlighting
the link between obesity and adverse
Health outcomes is that we moving
forward actually if we're going to make
the population more resilient for the
next pandemic God forbid it happened it
happens anytime soon is to make our
um you know our metabolic Health as best
as possible through you know dietary
changes getting good sleep going back to
the basics keeping stress levels low
meditation I'm sure these are all things
that you are a strong proponent of of
course and that's what I would say
people can do and be proactive about
yep I would also say you know this was a
very painful way to learn certain things
uh in the book I mentioned before
hunter-gatherer's Guide to the 21st
century
um not only did Heather and I say that
we thought vaccines were one of the
three great medical interventions in all
of history which I still believe though
now with a caveat
um but we also took a strong position uh
against the likely utility of
supplementation
um
on the basis that by and large a good
diet ought to provide you what you need
which is something I now do not believe
I know better in fact in at least one
case where most of us are chronically
deficient in vitamin D because diet is
not the mechanism through which you
procure it and our lifestyles block us
from the contact with the Sun that would
produce normal amounts of it our
clothing the windows that Shield UV the
fact that we live indoors all of these
things cause us to be chronically
deficient especially if we live at high
or low latitudes and so in any case I'm
coming to understand that a that my
model was too simple also a good diet
means you don't need to supplement and
there's no benefit you know the only
reason you need to supplement is if
you're deficient that part is true but a
lot of us are deficient and maybe in
more than one thing because our highly
novel Lifestyles block the normal way in
which we'd accrue these things
yeah 100 and vitamin D has so many
important roles in the body as a
pro-hormone
um not just in bone health as you
mentioned in the immune system
um but even in heart health you know the
vitamin D deficiency is associated with
a six-fold increased risk of developing
Coronado disease so
um yeah I'm with you 100 and if you can
ideally get it obviously get it from
getting some good sun exposure but if
not then certainly through winter months
or if you're in a place where you don't
get much sun exposure then yeah
supplements are definitely the way
forward I'm 100 uh an advocate of
vitamin D yeah yeah well uh I'm also an
advocate of leveraging Technology
there's an app there may be more than
one but I use one called D minder which
tells you actually during what hours of
the day you are capable of making
Vitamin D from sun exposure you know
simply being in the sun doesn't do it
and the angle of the sun you'd be
surprised I'm now in a phase as I would
imagine you are you're you're in Britain
um in which it's impossible to make
vitamin D no matter how much light
you're exposed to and just simply having
a you know a a calculation that tells
you okay I did pretty good over the
summer making vitamin D but I should be
supplementing because I can't be making
it until I think sometime in late
February
that's an important an important piece
of information to have
um all right one last question from my
side you mentioned Sherlock Holmes I was
actually independently going to mention
Cheryl outcomes for a very different
reason
uh I have been stunned
I have been introduced to many extremely
high quality people like yourself
through being a coveted dissident and uh
just simply encountering people who have
faced incredible pushback in order to do
the right thing and to protect patients
and distribute information that some
very powerful force does not want
disgust
um but that said I've also been
surprised in the other direction some
people I would have expected to
emerge strongly at our side and to help
alert the world to the hazard that we're
facing from from Pharma corruption have
been silent and top of the list is
somebody I used to hold in the highest
regard Ben goldacre who probably is the
world's leading Authority on Pharma
corruption he's the dog that didn't bark
do you know have you any idea how it is
that somebody who knows as much about
how this process works faced with such
an obvious pattern of Pharma corruption
is simply uh Missing in Action
I I really don't know I've I've followed
Ben goldacre's work it's inspirational
he has been very quiet only Bender
really knows the answer
um I can only guess and this is a guess
that maybe
um you know he decided it may have been
too much for him to carry on that
campaign maybe he um has decided to
spend more time with his family maybe he
has
um become closer to some of the
establishment figures and therefore
doesn't want to call them out so it
could be any or all of the above or none
of the above I honestly don't know but
it's a good point Brett um you know Ben
has been one of my Inspirations in terms
of his work
um but certainly in the last few years
he's been very very quiet on the farmer
pharmaceutical industry stuff all right
well maybe he'll see this and I hope
that he will uh realize that if he
stands up and helps us understand this
phenomenon that he will be doing a
tremendous amount of good for his fellow
human beings which is certainly
something he's been interested in in the
past
all right anything else that you feel we
should have in this podcast
no I think the only thing again is um
people need to really just get a bit
more of a perspective to you know I
think in a reassuring way people need to
understand that Omicron what's
circulating is no worse than the flu now
which is great and effectively the
pandemic is over
um and uh without understanding the
numbers involved when it comes to risk
you know the people and members of the
public are vulnerable to exploitation of
their hopes and fears by commercial and
political interests and
um I I noted that it was very
interesting that just basically coming
back to covid risk one Poland Gallup
poll in America revealed that 50 of
Americans sought their risk of being
hospitalized with covid said early on in
the pandemic was one was um was 50 one
in two
when the actual figure was way less than
one percent
so it's just important to go back you
know I love numbers
um Brett I love explaining to patients
numbers in simple terms about risk and I
think that's something that um we've
lost in this whole narrative around the
pandemic because it's been very very
strongly fear-based and that in itself
is very damaging to mental health and
physical health
so really that's where I want to kind of
finish is that I think statistical and
health literacy needs to be something
that is is uh advocated for
um more and more when it comes to
translating medical evidence you know
most drugs for most people don't have
any benefit
and uh and I think people need to get
wise to that and realize that
um one of the things it doesn't mean
that drugs shouldn't be used but it you
know it means that we shouldn't neglect
um the impact of Lifestyle which doesn't
come with side effects and is likely to
improve the quality of your life
something that drugs for management of
chronic disease don't normally do
so really to finish is a good health
doesn't come out of a medicine bottle
and deal the solution to your ultimate
longevity and is is through the the um
you know through getting your your diet
right and reducing stress and and
focusing on meaningful relationships I
think the single biggest determinant of
happiness is Meaningful relationships
and because we have this Society in this
narrative that's been governed by a
psychopathic entity we are constantly
losing more and more access to the truth
and through Division and hostility our
capacity for empathy and what's
happening is we are being driven more
and more away from what it means to be
human
and we need to just regain that we need
to recapture that um for the sake of
humanity
well that's uh that's a lovely way of
putting it I am going to push back in
one way I would say fixing your
lifestyle does have side effects and
they're awesome
yeah absolutely all right well it's been
a real pleasure uh thank you for your
courage and your hard work and
um I uh I hope that we turn this around
I hope you're right that we are near a
Tipping Point because uh We've certainly
done a lot of damage
[Music]
thank you Brett all right thanks so much
[Music]